Крістіане Дростен, скільки ще нам доведеться жити з пандемією коронавірусу?
Дуже важко робити глобальні прогнози.
У нас дуже різні і по-різному складні ситуації в країнах Європи.
Зима буде непростою. Ми очікуємо появи вакцин протягом наступного року.
Думаю, це триватиме до кінця наступного року,
перш ніж значну частину населення зможуть забезпечити вакциною.
Тож ми не позбудемося масок найближчим часом.
Навіть коли ми почнемо робити щеплення,
більшій частині населення все одно доведеться носити маски.
У таких країнах, як Німеччина, де рівень захворюваності низький,
не буде нічого подібного до так званого колективного імунітету.
Це те, на що нам, мабуть, не варто розраховувати в жодній країні Європи.
В інших частинах світу ситуацію дуже важко оцінити.
Наприклад, в Африці ми маємо сигнали про нижчу захворюваність,
менш важку форму. Можливо, це пов’язано з віком,
адже слід враховувати, що зараз ми розглядаємо міські райони
на африканському континенті, де склад населення особливо молодий.
Які регіони у світі зараз викликають у вас найбільше занепокоєння?
Індія наразі викликає найбільше занепокоєння.
Вона має високу густоту населення.
Вірус поширюється, я б не сказав, що неконтрольовано, але майже так.
Далі, звичайно, регіони Південної Америки.
Я вже говорив про Африку,
ситуація на африканському континенті наразі є трохи загадковою,
але також у північній півкулі настає зима, і є регіони,
в тому числі в Європі, де мало контролю,
де країни зустрічають осінь з уже високим рівнем захворюваності
і де довіра і, скажімо так, стійкість медичних структур,
а також ступінь впливу системи охорони здоров’я є низькими.
Багато країн у світі все ще дивляться на Німеччину як на приклад,
де справи йшли більш-менш добре. Що у ФРН було зроблено правильно?
Вирішальним моментом було те, що Німеччина відреагувала дуже рано.
Не з точки зору календарних дат, а з точки зору
відносного моменту часу, коли обмеження контактів,
яке іноді називають локдауном, було запроваджено
з огляду на фактичний розвиток епідемії.
Отже, ми знали про наш стан епідемії,
спираючись на лабораторні тести, і ця широка доступність лабораторних тестів
вирізняла Німеччину від інших країн. Однією з причин цього є те,
що ми дуже швидко відреагували на лабораторному рівні.
Звичайно, ще одне пояснення - це те, що у нас епідемія почалася дещо пізніше.
Ви сказали, що нам доведеться ще доволі довго жити з масками,
навіть коли вже буде вакцина. Коли ми зможемо
знову обійняти одне одного: бабусь з дідусями, а також незнайомців?
Це буде залежати від регіону. В деяких частинах світу
я не був би здивований, коли побачив би там протягом наступного року
колективний імунітет. Але це означає, що вони пережили епідемію,
яка може не виглядати такою серйозною, враховуючи вікову структуру населення.
Ми вже говорили про Африку, де це може статися,
принаймні цього я бажаю, щоб африканське населення було захищене
завдяки великій частині людей молодого віку.
Це дуже оптимістичне сподівання.
В інших частинах світу, де концепція полягає у тому,
щоб уникнути широкомасштабної передачі вірусу
і чекати загальної вакцинації, ми можемо очікувати, що доведеться
носити маски до кінця 2021-го року. Це моє очікування.
Неможливо зробити точні прогнози, але наступний рік буде роком,
коли ми будемо носити маски.
Дуже дякую, Крістіане Дростене.